all right I am live on the YouTube when
whenever I say via YouTube and then the
commenters are like he calls it the
YouTube like he's an eighty-year-old
yeah you know little tongue-in-cheek my
friend's little tongue-in-cheek all
right so so there's a lot going on as
you know as you are trapped in your
house possibly alone possibly with your
family maybe with some friends maybe
with some animals were all sort of in
the same situation when we're in South
Korea or were in Italy or in Belarus or
the United States or Canada or Mexico or
anywhere else there's various degrees of
quarantine there's various degrees of
lockdown but there is something truly
unprecedented happening at a worldwide
scale and it's not that we've never had
pandemics before but the way that we can
actually communicate through this the
way we can share information the way
that lies can spread the way the truth
can spread the way that our leaders can
guide us in a positive direction or
guide us in a negative direction there's
so many things happening right now that
are just completely have never been done
before and you know unfortunately it
doesn't seem like we have a lot of
people that are making real sense of it
you know when when the IDW the
intellectual dark web thing was burning
real hot like a year and a half two
years ago the the real key to the whole
thing was it wasn't something actually
that special or unique except that we
live in an odd time was just that we had
a bunch of people who fought all sorts
of different things right i always use
ben shapiro and sam harris as the best
examples of this two guys who believe in
completely different things at every
level from abortion to taxes to you know
the biggest questions about the universe
and god and belief and all that that we
were all just willing to try to make
sense of the world together and i think
that's really what we need more of now
and that's why i thought this week for
today actually because you guys know i
keep a whole bunch of books these are
all books of former guests on the set
that i keep here so you got to be a
guest that i like if you make it onto
onto the set here and i thought one of
the things that I'll do is I'm gonna be
doing these direct messages every Monday
and Wednesday live
is that once a week I will I will talk
about a couple of the books that have
influenced me some of the people that
I've talked to and why the things that
they write about in these books are
actually relevant today so that's what
we're gonna do today these livestreams
are gonna be about 20 minutes long and
I'm taking questions from you guys at
Rubin report calm that's the only place
we're taking the questions we're not
taking them on YouTube we're not taking
them on Facebook or Twitter or Instagram
or pin stag Ram or anything else or
tick-tock for you kids out there we're
just taking them that Reuben report calm
and by the way you can get ad free video
and you get our full videos 5 days early
so our interview with Bret Easton Ellis
which clip one went up yesterday on
YouTube the full video the full
hour-long conversation is already up at
Reuben report calm and free blah blah
blah okay so I want to talk about these
two books I'll start actually with with
this one twelve rules for life by mr.
Jordan Peterson as you guys know I was
on tour with Jordan for about a year and
a half we went on I don't know somewhat
something like 20 countries and a
hundred twenty stop to an unbelievable
toward not only did I get to visit all
these places in the United States that I
had never been to all these cities in
the middle of the country that I had
never been able to visit before but we
went to Sweden and we went to the UK and
we went to Finland and just all of these
places and Denmark tons of stuff up in
Canada
and actually we were gonna plan to do
more and then you know things got a
little nutty but what I realized during
the tour was that this wasn't just like
some thing that some guy wrote so he
could sell some books it was something
incredible he's something that was
actually bringing thousands and
thousands of people together every night
all over the world to take their lives a
little more seriously to sort of sit up
straight stand up straight with their
shoulders back and and confront the
world in the best way they could
possibly do it and I saw night after
night people that were turning their
lives around one of the chapters
actually in my upcoming book which
finally I could say is coming out this
month on April 28th is about what it was
like to tour with Jordan and some of the
lessons that I've learned and how I've
incorporated them into my own life but I
want to hit a couple a couple rules that
that I don't talk about that often but I
think are extremely valuable right now
so rule number nine is assume that the
person you are listening to might know
something that you don't and this is
really interesting because right now
we're just inundated with voices right
and and our most trusted voices are our
media voices often are misleading us
completely I don't know if you guys saw
this one a couple days ago Rachel Maddow
was or about about ten days ago now
Rachel Maddow was talking about how
Trump this ship is gonna come in and
it's gonna dock in New York City and
Trump was saying it's it'll be here by
next week and she's going on and on how
it won't be there and that basically it
was gonna be an extra Hospital they
weren't gonna take coronavirus patients
there but they were gonna take other
patients so that the regular hospitals
could deal with the coronavirus patients
and she kept saying it's never gonna
happen it's never gonna happen next week
anyway it turned out that it happened
like nine days later but her point
wasn't oh it's gonna happen it's not
gonna happen next week or nine days
later her point is he's just a liar and
a buffoon and of course it did happen
and that's just one of a million
examples you know another one Chris
Hayes on MSNBC
he's been tweeting how China is quite
literally doing a better job at their
coronavirus response than us and then of
course it just comes out today that that
china is fudging the numbers which we
all knew like why would China be giving
us their real numbers of course so the
problem is that when someone's talking
to you they might know something you
don't but you have to be really careful
about it now because the trusted names
aren't that trusted right now and one of
the things that I've had the but
actually say it's a blessing a blessing
of is is that I get to sit across from
interesting people every week and I
always try to sit there as if they do
know something that I don't know and I
think one of the reasons that I'm able
to communicate a lot of ideas in a
somewhat simple fashion I suppose is
because I take what a lot of these
people say and I incorporate it and I
compare it and contrast it to the things
that I talk about and that I believe so
I think this is one of the best things
that you can do right now is when you're
talking to somebody assume they know
something you don't maybe they know
something about
survival so survival skills or maybe
they know something about fitness or
maybe they know something about about
gardening or something that is valuable
right now that is valuable to you right
now but it doesn't mean just believe
everything everyone says it just means
that somebody might know a little bit
more might have some value and by the
way I mentioned this on Twitter
yesterday but in the last it's three
weeks or so that we've been you know in
lockdown over here you guys know I got
Clyde or we got Clyde two weeks ago and
it's when I'm walking a dog again and
it's very different I assure you walking
a 16 year old dog with cancer to a
one-year-old you know full of life dog
so he's mostly dragging me I'm not sure
who's walking who but there are so many
people out on the street and I have met
more of my neighbors in the last three
weeks and now know people by name and a
few people have recognized me you know
your studio is right over there that's
quiet I just saw him on Fox News you
know some whatever but the point is that
knowing your neighbors right now knowing
that may they might know something that
that's going on in the neighborhood that
might be relevant or if there was a
crime in the area or something so one of
the little pieces of advice I would give
you guys is to is to meet some people
and talk to us talk to the people in
your immediate community we don't do it
you know I lived in New York City for
many years many people live in apartment
buildings where there could be somebody
next to you literally in the apartment
next to you and you never say hi to them
for all the years you get in the air
elevator and you just stare in separate
direction so I think that's a good one
and then the other one that I wanted to
touch is rule number six which is set
your house in perfect order before you
before you criticize the world setting
your house in perfect order is seriously
hard work and I don't know that anyone
is doing it all the time I can tell you
for myself that since this tour and in
the last two years of my life I've done
a better job of setting my house in
order than ever before I've really been
trying to deal with whatever whatever
issues I have whatever outstanding
things I have with people and family
members and the rest of it I am not
perfect at it for sure but I think
mostly what we see in the in the
conversation online is people whose
lives are chaotic they don't necessarily
know what they believe they're not doing
what they want to do in life they are
not in good relationships all that and
they're just expressing that on the rest
of the world right there so it's like if
you get your stuff together like be able
to sit there again stand up straight
with your shoulders back know that your
stuff is basically in order so that when
you're talking to people you can do it
in an honest and open way and then if
you do that I think you can spark that
in somebody else and I see this all the
time with people so yeah so all right so
let's leave it at that cuz cuz I've
already gone ten minutes and we're only
doing these for 20 minutes and I want to
talk about zero to one so and I think
most of you probably have read twelve
rules for life and if you haven't it
would be it would be good to pick up a
copy now and it's old something like six
or seven million copies some something
crazy like that and and I and I know the
Jordan will be back and in good shape
soon enough so the other book that I
wanted to talk about which is definitely
not quite as dense as twelve rules for
life over rules for life is a seriously
dense dense book and this this will take
your days if not weeks to read and
you're gonna want to reread a lot of the
sentences and I was I was reading some
of it last night and it's like a type of
book where you could read three
sentences and then you want to just go
back no did I really kind of chew on
that properly this other book that I
wanted to talk about is zero to one by
Peter teal Peter teal of course is the
tech billionaire at Adam on the show
we've actually become pretty good
friends and and he's a good guy but I
think genuinely one of the best thinkers
we have and a contrarian think or a guy
who took his tech company out of Silicon
Valley because he was so sick of what
the diversity memo and social justice
had done to the thinking in Silicon
Valley so that it couldn't make good
products anymore and that's what he
cares about making good products doing
doing good business starting new
startups coming up with new ideas so he
left San Francisco to move his operation
down to LA and believe it or not in Los
Angeles right now there is an actual
interesting intellectual circle
happening here you know you wouldn't
think of it you think of ultra lefty
sort of mind controlled corroded
Hollywood but you know Shapiro's down
here and Dennis Prager is down here and
the whole Prager u team and the daily
wire guys there's a lot of interesting
people that are in this area now that so
there's something sort of breaking here
so 0 to 1 the the subtitle is
on startups or how to build the future
and I thought I would just read the
short back paragraph because I think
this is this is the key and this is why
I think it's I think it's sort of
valuable right now in the midst of this
as we're all sort of rethinking the way
we want to react with the world and
maybe rethinking what kind of job we
want and what do we want to do with our
lives and the rest of it so it's easier
to copy a model than to make something
new doing exactly sorry doing what we
already know how to do takes the world
from 1 to n adding more of something
familiar but every time we create
something new we go from 0 to 1 the act
of creation is singular as is the moment
of creation and the result is something
fresh and strange this book is about how
to get there
so the best way to explain this would be
like if let's say there's right we all
know what uber is if you now create
another app that does something similar
to Ober like lyft you went from one to
end you just maybe did something a
little bit different maybe your
algorithms a little bit different maybe
cars can get there quicker something
like that
but to go from zero to one is to
actually create something that is truly
new so one of the examples he uses it
here is like the Bill Gates of tomorrow
is not going to create Microsoft right
he's not gonna create Windows he's gonna
create something absolutely new maybe it
could be an offshoot of what a
futuristic operating system or something
like that but it'll be something new and
the reason I think that this is relevant
right now is because there is
opportunity right now like most of we're
pretty much all trapped in our houses
right now we're really able to think
about things differently I know for a
fact I've been talking to my friends
that live in big cities and they're
talking about maybe not even going back
some of them have met have left the
cities in the midst of this the amount
of people that are now telecommuting
that are realizing why am i spending so
much time driving to work getting on a
train all of that one of the things I
write about in my book my dad who just
retired at 71 years old he took I grew
up in Long Island he worked in a we grew
up in Island he worked in New York City
he took an hour train ride basically
every day five days a week for something
like 40 years to go to
work and why did he do it he did it so
that he could you know have things so
that he could have a house and cars and
take good care of his kids and all of
those things and he did do that but
those 40 years of to our commutes five
days a week adds up to something like
two hours of his life now my dad's
actually pretty highly functional so he
would read and do some other stuff
probably napped every now and again too
but the point is maybe we don't need to
do those traditional things and I think
the way we get to that now is there's a
lot of people really thinking about how
to change the world right now and and I
would really recommend this book I mean
this is the type of book you that you
could you can actually read this
probably in one sitting two sittings at
most and really think about how do we go
from zero to one and whatever it is that
you do you know you mean whatever
whatever business it is you do whatever
you care about like there's there's new
opportunity out there I don't know
exactly what it is I think I think what
I'm doing
here is a slight version of a zero to
end and that I'm using all of the
capabilities that YouTube and social
media and video and all of that have to
present something honest and true and
decent that's what that's a one to end
cuz I didn't invent anything the zero to
one that I think I've done is what we're
starting to do with locals calm which is
create digital homes for creators which
is completely against what big tech
wants big tech wants you to be reliant
on them they want to own your data they
want to own your content you've created
something really great with locals calm
and by the way in though we just closed
our funding round but we raised a pretty
decent amount of money I don't get any
of it by the way to run locals and we're
getting a really nice response the
company's growing as I said we're hiring
and that to me would sort of be a zero
to one thing in that I am NOT trying to
recreate the Internet as is I want to
create a completely new situation so
that's my little my little version of
that anyway I think both of these books
Jordan's book twelve rules for life and
that it will help you with the tools
that you need to sit up Stan I keep
saying sit up because I'm sitting but
stand up straight with your shoulders
back and think of about your life
seriously right now like know that maybe
you don't want to be in the job you're
in if that's how you're feeling but you
just can't quit tomorrow because you
still may have bills to pay and things
like that like really take your life
seriously and then once you do that
I think you can start working on the
stuff that Tila writes about here in in
zero to one which is how do I want to
put something into the world that is new
and different and can I do it and he
talks about how to do it from a start-up
perspective but there's also two ways
that you can do it maybe you have just
some little gadget that we all suddenly
need because we're all trapped at home I
mean there's all sorts of interesting
things so that's that and then I want to
do a little bit of Q&A I know you guys
ask me a bunch of interesting stuff so
I'm only doing the Q&A as I said from
the from the subscribers at Rubin
report.com so I'm going to knock out a
couple questions for you guys
and by the way if you are interested in
books my book which here I'm gonna get
up for a set my book this is a galley
copy so these are the ones that we send
out to the press which are out right now
obviously the the real book is hardcover
and there's a blurb by Jordan on the
front and in the back there's actually
Jordan and Peter teal and Eckart Tolle
and Tucker Carlson and Ben Shapiro and
Larry King quite a collection to people
my book is coming out April 28th it's
what I think about freaking everything I
think it's probably the best most
professional thing I've done you can go
to dumper in this book calm or you can
get it on Amazon I also did the
audiobook which is actually super fun to
do okay so there we go and now let me
just get to some of your questions
Oh somebody I like this one I'll start
with this one pink Adam a fox said I'd
like to know what your personal 13th
rule is I like this one and I think
you're gonna know why I like it
get a pet of some kind we have one fish
there we've a betta fish his name's John
got him about a year or so he's in a
nice little 12 gallon cube tank nobody
else betta fish it's also known as the
Japanese fighting fish you know they
don't like to be with other fish they'll
kill everybody pretty much but there is
something about getting on the morning
turning the light on in that tank
feeding that fish like it gives you a
little bit of responsibility but more
important than the fish obviously having
a dog like I got to take walks every day
so it helps on the exercise for cuz I
got to get that dog out of the house
otherwise he gets the zooms and he's
like freakin nuts but not only that like
having the responsibility if you've got
to feed this dog you got to make
the dog doesn't have fleas you got to
make sure the dog has water and exercise
and all the rest of it I think when you
have something else outside of yourself
that you have to take care of it
actually forces you to take more care of
yourself you know you mean like if
you're doing drugs and you don't have
any money and anything else well that's
you can punish yourself right and you
can starve yourself to death and never
brush your teeth and the rest of it but
suddenly if you don't have any money and
you can't buy dog food you might look at
that animal ago well you know it's one
thing to do it to yourself but another
thing to starve an animal something like
that so I think actually having an
animal and by the way right now we're
all trapped in our houses having an
animal is also comforting and fun and
and provide safety you know something
like there's a 90% chance something like
this a 90% chance that less chance that
if you have an animal of dogs
specifically in your house that your
house will be robbed so there's a lot of
reasons for it but I think there's
something about just like having
responsibility for something outside
yourself I guess a kid would be a good
one for that too all right just a couple
more let's see California's governor
this is from torrid lover has released
from jail at least 14 criminals that are
murderers and rapists do you think this
is tyranny do you think this is time to
get a gun well I also saw yesterday that
New York has released 900 criminals so
think about what we're doing right now
we have some states saying you can't buy
guns and at the same time releasing
criminals back out into the streets now
have all these criminals been fully
vetted vetted not only in terms of will
they commit crimes again but have they
been absolutely fully vetted that had
betted it has it been absolutely
confirmed that they don't have
coronavirus perhaps they don't have
symptoms but have these people gone
through the testing properly and now
we're just putting these people back out
into the population
I mean if really if releasing nine
hundred criminals in New York City makes
sense then we have other problems with
our prison system now I agree we have
other problems with our prison system
but the idea that somehow releasing nine
hundred people will be such a relief on
the system that it's worth taking that
kind of risk
is absolutely crazy so well to your
question about guns I think a lot of
people are rethinking all sorts of stuff
I think you got a lot of lefties
suddenly
wait a minute wait a minute maybe I
shouldn't have been as against guns
because I want to be able to protect my
own family in my own house which we all
should be able to do I think we have to
be very leery right now about government
overreach at all fronts you know de
Blasio the mayor of New York who's a
complete lunatic you know he said this
thing about if you are a temple or a
church he did say mosque interestingly
but he said if you're a temple or a
church he said and you would still have
people get together and we warned you we
could potentially close you permanently
it's like that's how is what laws that
what law is that now I'm for I'm all for
like some basic guidelines in making
sure people don't congregate right now
and you and you hope that people do what
they're supposed to do but what if what
if some group does it some let's say a
temple or a church doesn't they get 20
people together and and then what
happens is they get closed but then they
decide they have new leadership and
they're gonna reopen it now you can't
reopen it because it's permanently
closed I mean this is just we really
have to just be careful there's a lot of
opportunists who would love to have more
power over your life right now and we
have to just be very very careful that
we don't just grant them power because
we're a little bit scared right now
Jessica asks chocolate or vanilla the
important questions you know I've been a
chocolate person my whole life in the
last six months or so I've been kind of
coming around to vanilla believe it or
not I've got a little vanilla oat almond
cream in my coffee right now and it's
delicious all right guys I've done I've
done the 20 minutes here I hope this
gave you a little bit of sanity again
the books that I would recommend right
now if you're really thinking about
trying to do something new this is it
zero to one by Peter TL you can read it
in a day and it'll give you some really
great tools and if you just are trying
to get your stuff together so maybe you
want to read this one before you do that
one get your house in order first then
change the world 12 rules for life by
Jordan Peterson and then if you do all
that and you're feeling good about
yourself and you want to know what I
think about everything that will be out
on April 28th is don't burn this book
which you can go to don't burn this book
um all right we're gonna keep doing
these every Monday and Wednesday our
interview with Bret Easton Ellis part
one is up already on YouTube full
episode is up at Rubin report com it's a
nice little break from everything going
on right now and we'll keep going guys
so I hope you're all good and if you
want to communicate with me directly
Rubin report calm that is all good luck
out there